now I wanted to point out the future of
society I don't say this in a happy way
but if I had to predict what I would see
in 50 years this is what I would guess
marriage and relationships really are
going to go away except for the upper
class the elite I do believe will still
marry but I believe it will continue to
disappear in the middle class the reason
being richer men are able to better
fight in court and they're better able
to you know afford a wife and recover if
it goes south now that's not to say that
I haven't seen rich men get royally
screwed over in divorce court that
absolutely has happened but in my
experience it's the middle class
American workers that are not able to
recover so where does that leave us with
all of these single mothers on the
market you are going to see older women
start to live together so there is an
article that I saw I believe showed me
what I think the future is which I can't
even imagine how bad of a child can you
imagine having Four Women in the same
house
four single mothers oh my God and women
it's not like women get together and
become better people it's like we become
worse people so
um okay so this article discusses the
Journey of four single mothers who
jointly purchased a four unit apartment
building in Washington DC to build
equity and share housing costs this
existing floor plan of the 1927 building
presented challenges particularly for
one of the mothers who needed more space
and privacy for her two kids they hired
architect linelle Schneider to redesign
the floor plan investing forty thousand
dollars in renovations to create a more
practical and efficient layout
schinder's expertise in compact Living
Spaces and her commitment to co-housing
projects helped transform the apartments
into a more suitable living arrangement
for the group they also considered
long-term expansion options including
the possibility of additional dwelling
units to economy to accommodate the
growing needs of the families and
generate extra incomes overall The
Single mother's collaborative approach
to housing and their willingness to
invest in the redesign of their
Apartments to meet their unique needs
showcases the advantages of shared
living arrangements and thoughtful
architectural planning and addressing
modern housing Holly Harper is the
founder of anagram Consulting blue bikes
Communications and siren Foundry she's
also founded a company known as Street
Pearl oh hey look at that look at that
now you're going to see a rise of single
people you're going to see a rise of
couples without children and you're
going to see a rise of single mothers
you are going to see Society reshape or
a post-marriage world and I predict that
you will you will absolutely in fact
start to see single mothers pull their
resources as well as elderly women
coming together pooling their resources
and having houses together now we have a
single mother that is talking about the
experience of being a single mother
let's pull it up I know it's crazy
because I um joke a lot about all
being single and
but I'm 46 years old
[Music]
and while I'm getting ready for surgery
and everything
it dawned on me that I'm 46 years old
and I don't have a husband to take care
of me
I don't have a husband too
help me
get ready
being single and 46.
sucks
[Music]
it just sucks
and I'm tired and I make jokes
about
the buffoons that I have been
encountering
in in dating this is my reality and this
those stories are the that's
available
because all the good men have gotten
married
in their 20s and 30s
because they're good men I'm not blaming
it all on men because women are
they've batshit crazy too
so
but um this is my reality not anybody
else's I wanted to
her mentality and the thing is women's
words mean something and they reveal
something
so what did she say I don't have a
husband to take care of me
but it's supposed to be the other way
around
I mean the true definition of a wife is
a help mate you're supposed to take care
of your husband now obviously obviously
it goes both ways but my point is
typically
when you hear women's reasoning for
wanting a husband and it's a selfish
thing it's about them typically that's
the reason why they haven't been able to
get one because selfish women do not end
up getting husbands they end up dying
alone so the comment section said I
don't feel sorry for you you made the
bed now lie in it um Lion raw says this
is what they wanted
and it's true alphonbo don't say that
you're beautiful I'm sure you'll find
the perfect person God has a plan for
everybody
no no no no no stop saying that guys
like
this is why like guys as women we just
need to be sick of this I am
tired of being pandered to no most women
are not gonna have a happy ending
feminism has lied to women and there's
an entire generation of women coping
with the fact that most will be alone in
the next 50 years yes yes yes and most
women that woman should not expect to
get a husband ever she can hope for one
if she gets one then great
but I would argue that telling that
woman to make a financial plan of how
she is going to spend the next 50 years
of her life is a far better option than
selling the dream that there is a
husband waiting for you at the end of
this that is not the reality for a lot
of women and the issue you get is all of
these influencer women will come out
saying they're so happy single Emily
radakowski said that but are most women
as attractive as Emily or have the same
Financial opportunities as Emily the
answer is no most women are living
paycheck to paycheck they make about 35
000 a year and a large majority are in
debt women have so much debt so what is
going to happen to them in their old age
women make poor decisions and keep
expecting men to bail them out but one
day men are gonna stop bailing them out
and we are going to see a huge rise in
the number of homeless women
Four Leaf biking are we not better than
this gentleman no one deserves to be
miserable and alone
look at this just because this girl made
poor decisions in her youth is no reason
for her to continue to be miserable
she's got a life ahead of her to find
her person she just needs to go find
them have some empathy it's pitiful
people might think I'm mean but I am
just not in the business of selling
dreams I won't do it I refuse like if I
don't think something is likely if I
know that the chance a woman has is if
unmarried by 35
actually if a woman is single at 30 not
in a relationship she's actually more
likely to not get married than to get
married so at 30 if she has a boyfriend
her odds are a little bit better but if
she doesn't have a boyfriend because it
on because on average it takes men three
years to marry you so that's something
as women we have to take into account
yes on average it's going to take three
years to convince a guy to marry you so
I'm just not in the business of selling
dreams at 46 it's probably over
um I hope she has savings and what I
would do if I were her is I would figure
out a financial plan on how to live the
rest of my life alone
um I would also look for a husband in
the process and see what they what what
you can do but I'm just not in the
business of selling dreams and and I
think that women are just Souls of dream
over and over again God's timing
it'll happen when really you have to put
effort into making things happen